by the power of castle hate skull
i am eleanor carly and you are in for
one of the biggest treats you've ever
had in your life i'm not talking about
rice krispie treats i'm talking about an
intellectual feast for your mind that is
sweet
af
now
a lot of people have been asking me mark
you're fantastic on this podcast just by
yourself have you ever thought about
having a guest
in the long form where you don't do your
podcast and then sneak in a guest at the
end just to have a little five-minute
segment on something that is relegated
to a subsection of the podcast that
would be a chapter in the youtube video
if we did chapters on the videos and
maybe that's something we can work on
for the future
the answer is yes i've thought about
this and come to the conclusion
that i in the future
very near future in fact will be having
guests so i wanted to bring that up
right up front
so we can talk about the kinds of guests
that i want to have on now sure i have
so many friends so many acquaintances so
many people begging me to get on the
podcast
daily mark please let me on that's just
a solo podcast
but if the format ever changes
due to high demand
maybe i'll sneak in
in all seriousness
i do have some ideas for people who i'd
like to have on
some people i've talked to before about
coming on
uh gregor gallagher quinoa body guys who
have talked to in real life i think he
has a lot of interesting things to say
not only about fitness but also about
you know
psychology about business about
self-improvement those are kind of the
people you know doesn't have to be just
fitness related of course i'd like to
talk to some people who i admire
in the realm of fitness biohacking uh
different things like that so i think of
leo rex from leo and longevity
vigorous steve um who i've communicated
with a little bit also
um lives out in thailand and just guys
like that who have a tremendous
wealth of information
on the topics relevant to this podcast
uh also guys who i haven't talked with
like
juji mufu who just seemed to have you
know i like his energy i like his
approach to fitness i like that he makes
this fun because ultimately that's kind
of what i think about
this podcast is
having fun
relating it to fitness making this a
fun environment and a fun thing to think
about going to the gym and getting
active and not seeing it as a punishment
and that's always a running theme in
this podcast and when i approach you
know people to where they approach me
and we have a conversation about you
know how to get themselves out of a
slump
it usually revolves around
how to have a more positive outlook
on fitness long term so a guy like that
kind of fits that bill or uh you know
eric bugenhagen
rick the stick he's a wwe guy right now
but he
came up as a
division one wrestler at wisconsin and
was a strength and conditioning coach
and also
you know tremendous amount of
information as far as how to program how
to lift he's extremely strong he's an
all-natural
a lot of cool things but also just as a
guy who
has fun with it doesn't take himself too
seriously
and
i think that comes across in his social
media so that's the
the general approach i'd be taking other
guys like greg buscett or jeff nipperty
these big names so i think you know they
provide high quality information and a
lot of people
relate to their mindset and you know
again the kinds of guests i'd like to
have but i'd like to have more
interesting interviews than just
stuff that they put out before like tell
me about working out the nuts and bolts
the x's and those because in order to
get that kind of content from their page
in most cases so
i'd like to expand that conversation and
try to get at the underpinnings of you
know how they approach fitness and
how they build psychological resilience
you know
how they kind of treat recreational drug
use if any like we talk about with with
psychedelics um
you know things like how they keep
themselves motivated and how to manage
their time that's one that i really need
personally
you know so it's a private convo that
i'm going to share with you
how do you
build a youtube page from the ground up
and become a millionaire using clickbait
titles now i don't want to know that but
some people are good at that so
i wanted to
before we get into some other sections
i'll just ask you this if you want to
see anybody
specifically put it in the comments give
me some ideas maybe even people that
i've mentioned if that's really exciting
to you you can be like yeah put this
person on
then would be don't freaking think and
then count on yourself
huh
what do we have next you know
the amber herd trial so you've been
keeping up with all the aftermath too
because we
we established that you're really into
it during the trial right i'm over it
dude yeah okay yeah totally over it
link
so
in our first interview since the trial
this clip has been going around
totally viral but it's you know i'm not
i'm just gonna do an imitation of what
she says because the girl the the
interviewer asks her
all her interviews since
the trial had been totally disastrous
and she's been trying to blame johnny
depp for everything and saying you know
the the jury was totally tainted by how
good of an actor he is and how popular
is and you know because of
his his character and pirates of the
caribbean that's really why they gave
him the favorable verdict and
uh you know jack sparrow is who they're
looking at and because of that
she's uh guilty of defamation apparently
in her mind one of the funniest quotes
from the interview that she gave
her first time speaking out publicly on
tv
since the trial she goes
um in response to a question
that said essentially depp's lawyers
accused you of giving the performance of
a lifetime you know this is in the
context of calling her out for her lies
and saying a lot of people said you
weren't telling the truth up there so
you keep insisting
that you haven't but you know you laid
all the evidence out and the jury said
you were lying and dep's lawyers said
afterwards you gave the performance of a
lifetime
and she looks perplexed and goes uh says
the lawyers
for the guy who convinced the world he
had scissors for fingers
and she says that in all seriousness
like that's a devastating rebuttal as if
the world was under the impression that
johnny depp literally had scissors for
fingers um and i just want to point out
the condescension inherent in that
comment because i think
there are so many things that people get
away with
in using manipulative language and it
swaps one thing out for the other
and implies one thing you know as if
it's a factual reality that everyone in
the world
believed that johnny depp literally had
fingers that were scissors in real life
and this wasn't fictional he was playing
a character that also happened to have
scissors for fingers
but johnny depp in real life was born
with scissor fingers
and must have had them surgically
removed if they're not there anymore but
i wanted to examine
and talk about how people like that
manipulative people
will swap one thing out for the other
and say something
that's not true
but
in order for you to rebut it you have to
go wait there's a small little thing
he he gave a convincing performance in
the context of a movie
but instead of saying that you're saying
he convinced the world right he gave a
convincing performance in a you know
piece of cinema but that doesn't mean
the same thing as convincing the world
that he had scissors for his fingers
right so
i think
even
in that moment you know you can see this
pattern
of manipulative speaking and i just
encourage everybody to
think about that as they approach the
world and anybody
saying things to you that like
they sound ridiculous examine the
grammar of that sentence and say is
there anything that's imprecise about
that is there anything that's off is
there anything that isn't actually true
even though you're presenting it as some
sort of fact that it sort of it lands
like an effective rebuttal
but in reality it's not
let's just jump to liver king meme of
the week okay
can we do it
okay let's take a look at this
ouch
i want to know if all this business
about the affection quota is true or
false well i brought you the queen the
affection quota your own words
of course it's true and if you don't do
it you should
and then he pans to the
hand holding so i guess this is it must
be an inside joke or something that uh i
don't know about
with the holding of hands but
she looks like she's reading off a
teleprompter for a one sentence
statement
which is fine
not everyone's a performer
but uh okay
now if you've made it this far you might
be wondering mark
did you take your kratom today up you
bet your bottom dollar i did now you
might also be wondering did you veer
from the path did you go somewhere other
than happy hippo herbals.com well i can
proudly say that no i have not i've
stayed consistent i've stayed loyal and
i'm using the brand that i like because
of the delivery mechanism variety
whether you want powders whether you
want a shot whether you want a
convenient pill that you can keep in
your pocket
and hide from anybody who you don't want
knowing
your secret to mental acuity it's happy
hippo herbals.com and if you go there
right now and use promo code thick boy
with three c's you'll get 20 off and
that's not just me blowing smoke up your
butt that's me promising you
that it's a fact you will get that
amount off and you will also get that
amount off for the rest of your life if
you keep using the same promo code so
would you help a brother out and type
that in just to let him know like oh
yeah
i'm getting the message this is the
place to go
for the kratom
you know some people have been asking me
recently mark
when you wear your oak and stone
clothing is it something you can
exclusively pair with
jeans and boots or nice pants when
you're going out to dinner or on a date
or you know maybe giving a ted talk in
front of thousands of adoring fans well
no that's not the case you see it's
summertime and here i have on the gray
short sleeve button up
it fits these pythons perfectly size xl
chances are it's going to fit you too
whatever you think your size is go ahead
order it if it doesn't fit send it back
get a new one
but what do i have on underneath this
table well that's the question of the
day isn't it and i'm here to reveal to
you
that i in fact have shorts on
and guess what
they pair perfectly i have a nice little
summer outfit and i will tell you
something honestly right now when i go
on flights nowadays i think about what i
wear because i get hot on planes
every single time i fly now i wear my
oak and stone because it in fact is the
most breathable stuff that i own
it doesn't seem that way because it's
very sturdy the fabric is really nice
and it feels thick it doesn't feel like
you could rip it you know like something
from h m
but
when it comes to actually feeling
comfortable and not overheating you
i guess that's a testament to the
quality because i feel
you know
i feel totally breathable right
it's thick it's gray marked that must be
a winter shirt
because i'm in the sun in california
right now in june
pairing it with some tight little shorts
and i'm feeling amazing and you will too
use code hella at checkout for 10 off
i'm getting word that some people are
going they can see that you're using my
link but then they see
you're not using the checkout oh i guess
you don't like money okay no that's cool
just if you like money and saving money
on things use code hella h-e-l-l-a for
ten percent off
or pay full price the choice is yours
maybe you like giving money to open snow
and i'm not going to stop you from doing
that but at least check out the website
you know
say what's up to ricardo you know what
let's go back to sup well i have some
stuff i need to address
now in the last few episodes
there was quite a controversy stirred by
me making the claim that i would give
somebody's public details
or i would make public somebody's
life details such as name address etc
workplace
now
apparently some people out there really
didn't like that
and you know if you're watching this for
the first time i was speaking about it
in the context of
the top one of the top posters on reddit
uh you know which is a hate
subreddit for
the fighter and the kids specifically on
that reddit right so however many
thousands of comments however many
hundreds of posts over the course of a
few years
now
um
that
promise load i didn't mention anybody
specifically
and i guess i just want to give myself
credit for that because it's equivalent
to saying people who came to my page
after that right and i'll get into
something even more extreme that
happened
after people just made it ruckus about
me
threatening to dock somebody now
it's like saying you know i'm gonna kill
somebody after this podcast or i'm gonna
rob somebody after this podcast
if you're not making a threat against
anybody specifically
what are you doing you know you're like
talking about a hypothetical crime
against a non-existent person
i never mentioned any names i didn't
mention any
handles or anything like that
deliberately so because then it's not
any sort of specific threat to anybody
and even using the word docs is also an
umbrella term that implies private
details that one wouldn't want to get
out of the world now
i'll give you
an example of
something that might be a little thought
experiment for you
if i had a
reddit profile that was
called farc marley right
and then i also had a twitter profile
that was
uh you know farc marley and on that farc
marley twitter profile it said
owned by mark harley and then i also had
a instagram page that was mark harley
and i had all the details of what i do
for a living where i publicly post about
what i do for a living and the things
that i do and where i work and all that
information is publicly available online
and willingly put there in a social
media platform
designed to self-promote
is discussing those details if you went
on
uh you know a podcast and said
oh my god farc marley is mark harley
and he works at the place that he says
on his instagram
is that doxing
is that illegal
is that something that you think is any
worse than uh for example
you know calling somebody's sponsors on
a podcast
uh sending harassing messages to
somebody on instagram or on twitter
or to their email
or you know leaving anonymous threats on
the voicemail of somebody's mom all
these different things that
if you're part of the fighter in the
kids subreddit and condone those types
of activities by continuing to
participate in the subreddit and don't
seem to have an issue with it or have
never taken a stand against that type of
behavior except in the context of saying
don't make it known that you're doing
that because the subreddit might get
shut down
and then suddenly you care about
a discussion of giving out details that
are already public to the public
because you consider that doxxing
i think you're a hypocrite and i also
think you're naive and i also think you
don't know how language works and i
think if you actually think that i
committed a crime
by threatening
to talk somebody
which i didn't
then
you know maybe you have some research to
do into the law
maybe you're not an attorney right i had
somebody claiming they were an attorney
uh and this is after this happened which
i'm about to go into
an interesting little thing happened
the mere discussion
of somebody
who i didn't name by name or i didn't
name by handle
prompted one of the subreddit's top
users to delete their own profile a
prolific poster indeed
now
what would make that poster do that i
don't know maybe they had something
incriminating in what they posted that
they felt like they didn't want exposed
or they didn't want to bring any
attention to this maybe they felt like
this was going to be a reference to them
and therefore or maybe they just deleted
their profile out of nowhere
coincidentally
but in that person's absence
another fake or or a profile that was
potentially fake or potentially the same
person i don't know
but
uh
the username was
mc spitfire or mixed spitfire but i
assume emc spitfire
they shut down their own account right
this was one of the top posters on
reddit on the subreddit
after that
somebody
with a different username
that referenced mcspitfire in the
username
said this is mcspitfire
i've shut down my account and erased it
completely here's a video of me doing
that like a screen recording of me
shutting down my account and then
furthermore
i just wanted to let everyone know yes
it's true
mark harley has doxed me
and the quote was
uh he did it on the king and the sting
patreon pit
i don't even know what that means there
is no patreon pit i've never heard that
term in my life so it was news to me to
read that
and and see that somebody made up a term
to describe the place
that i doxed someone quote unquote they
made reference this post made reference
to people harassing him at work this
people you know made reference to
difficulties that they've encountered
they made reference to contacting a
lawyer to tell me uh or to to say that
you know i was going to be criminally
charged this person made reference to uh
the case being a slam dunk and telling
me that i was totally effed
which i get to laugh at because i go
yeah that didn't happen now turns out
though
a lot of people on the subreddit seem to
be very willing
to
believe anything without any
corroborating evidence now normally
you'd say like oh cool what episode was
that
where can i find that let's see a
screenshot of him writing it let's see a
screen recording or a video
a clip of mark saying
the thing that you said he said
before i take further action on that
but that doesn't exist because it didn't
happen
now
that didn't stop hundreds of people from
coming to my page
and harassing me in the dms in the
comments more posts about it spurring
youtube videos talking about me doxxing
somebody and i've already done it and
this is going to be the end of
you know the thick boy youtube channel
is gonna be end of my shows can be end
of the entire thick boy empire because
mark dock somebody something that didn't
happen
right
so
it was very funny and satisfying for me
to see them slowly start to realize this
there's people a few people going oh
wait wait so he's saying on his page
because i'd respond to a few people like
you know i i didn't do that or do you
mind telling me where that happened
because they were coming up he's like
you're going to jail you better watch
your back in real life you know making
threats to me
about my physical safety in real life
which is you know
not gonna intimidate me because of
course they're not gonna do anything but
uh
if you're if you're concerned about
doxing but then you're going to make
threats about something that didn't
happen uh you know based on
uh a defamation right because that's
what it is if you're telling me i
mark harley committed a crime in real
life
and uh i'm getting a lawyer to sue him
and he's totally f
well that's not true and the person
posting it knows it's not true because
they had no
uh
evidence of that obviously
and made it up out of thin air but
it's
very affirming to see that
so many hundreds of people on the
subreddit
they're willing to believe anything it's
naive and i think
that's the sort of microcosm for how
they behave in general
and
i guess the uh you know
it was just funny for me to see them
realize this have the mods have to take
it down back off and then see some of
these conspiracy theories come up like i
think mark wrote the post himself and
put it out there so that we'd attack him
it's like you're thinking way too many
steps ahead like
if you're bamboozled that easily you
know and then you're coming up with this
elaborate concoctive scheme to make
still make me the villain in this um
you know take a step back from the
internet
take a deep breath calm down
think about life touch grass as the gen
zers say
because
maybe you're just
not even stupid
just something to think about maybe you
need to look into things and maybe form
your own opinions
or ask for evidence of the things that
people claim are true before you go
harassing people on the internet just a
suggestion okay can we put that to rest
case you didn't add nope
[Laughter]
all right
then we can get on
to the sickest segment of this episode
called a lot of people been asking me
now a woman messaged me recently and
said mark
you're the most handsome
fitness influencer i've ever seen in my
life and
that's not to take anything away from
casey being the most handsome podcast
producer on the internet because those
are two separate categories ultimately
but she said i'm 5'3 and 245.
same yeah same as casey
now obviously this person is going to be
pretty overweight but they were saying
you know i worked with the trainer for
you know six months or some extended
period of time and they didn't lose a
single pound and they were very upset
about this
and
you know felt like they'd been lied to
and betrayed and came to me
you know to see if they could get some
tips and of course i want to help
somebody like this especially if you
feel like i've been bamboozled and there
are a lot of you know frauds in the
fitness industry who take advantage of
people who uh don't know any better
you're paying good money i was talking
to somebody recently who was like
this is a common scam these days where
somebody would be like you're getting
one-on-one coaching with me like former
mr olympia dorian yates and then it
turns out like you're really talking to
one of their assistants or whatever and
they're giving you super generic
programs it might even be like a bot
that's like you send them something and
it's like good job keep up the same
thing next week you know and it's like
individual coaching for three thousand
bucks for a few months or whatever it is
you know unless you're working with
dorian yates live in person you're
probably not getting
anybody but his assistant but that
format and that uh you know that scam
has now spread across the fitness
industry so this guy was dealing with
like a coach at a major university who
uh was doing sort of the same thing and
he asked like you know can i get an
email or sorry can i get an in-person
thing i don't really like this email
back and forth is it possible to just
ask you a question you know on the phone
for like a minute he was like no i can't
because i'm really busy because the
football season's coming up he's like
doesn't really make sense like it's
you know
it's june and i'm asking for a minute on
the phone
and i'm like well you're probably
getting scammed and it seems like a good
deal because like it's only 600 bucks
and it's like well yeah
and he's probably you know
got 500 people doing the same exact
thing
and you're not getting any of that
person's one-on-one time because they
are ultimately they're at the top of the
food chain for that university for the
athletics program if they're or you know
the doing anything revolving around the
gym so you're probably not getting that
person's one-on-one actual individual
time
but you can come dm me and it will be me
because i don't have any assistance
running my personal ig account except
casey occasionally going in there and
just trolling people like what's up you
know like he'll message dudes and stuff
like that i'm like you're cute like
wanna make out and they're like what and
then i get on there like who did you
know but he'd erase the message already
so it's like they are cute though yeah
you know what i mean right now
i'm not sending messages guys that
aren't cute yes
what's wrong with that yeah so it's like
his his cover for that is like
technically i'm being honest and you
agree to it
it's just like it puts me in a bit of a
pickle
when i ask these guys to tickle my
pickle
so back to the original story
this fat woman
this woman goes um
i'm 5'3 245 i was i was eating 1200
calories a day and i'm like i don't know
how you could actually i'm like did you
stick to that right because essentially
you're breaking the laws of
thermodynamics you know me i'm around
245 and i'm 6'3 that's a full foot
taller than this woman um
and if i were to eat 1200 calories a day
i would rapidly lose weight and she was
saying she didn't lose a pound
um i'm going through the checklist i'm
like have you have your had your thyroid
checked because that can be something
that actually does significantly slow
down your metabolism as opposed to
people kind of have a slow metabolism if
you haven't gotten that checked and you
don't have a thyroid disorder that's
probably not the core issue here so i'm
questioning i'm going what are the meals
what are the can you send me the meal
plan and she did and it seemed about
right it was kind of carb heavy like
a little bit of oatmeal and rice maybe
the breakfast was just like oatmeal and
an apple and i'm like where's the
protein so
perhaps a little bit light on the
protein for some of these meals but then
i get to you know day seven and it's
like free day
and i'm like what's a free day check i
can eat whatever i want and it's like as
long as i don't eat like as long as i
stop eating by 7 p.m or something like
that and i go well
here's the thing okay when you're trying
to create a caloric deficit
and you have eating habits that got you
up to 245 pounds
the thing is you can easily out eat that
deficit you know how many pounds can i
gain in a single day of binge eating
several
and i don't know how much of that
directly translates to fat but like
i could wake up at 240 and go to bed at
250 you know between water between
eating you know i can chop chug gallons
of water before to like i memorize it
right on the heavyweight limit like you
know if you're not past a certain if
you're not like 220 you can't wrestle a
heavyweight or whatever so it's like oh
[ __ ] i'm 213. i gotta chug you know
seven pounds of water before i step on
the scale
um
so you can do that
and gain weight and and you know then if
you're also eating cheesecake guess what
some of that's going to be actual weight
that you gain and throw off your you
know caloric deficit that's why i tell
people to think in terms of a weekly
caloric deficit or surplus if you're
trying to gain weight but you know it is
extremely easy
to throw off
several pounds of weight loss by one
reckless day of binge eating and
drinking so be mindful of that if you
have gone through your checklist and
said you know and i'm sticking to the
diet well you aren't eating 1200
calories a day on average
if you're taking one day
that throws off that average because you
ate 10 000 and think about that let's
take you know
if you're
normally eating uh you know 7 200
calories in a week um
and that's gonna create your deficit
you know could you at that weight eat
seven thousand calories in a single day
i know i easily could and you could too
probably it's not even that much you
know to eat an entire day
especially eating high fat high sugar
foods so
the moral of that whole story is
one of the first things you should check
off
is
a cheat day
you know maybe there's a cheat meal
maybe there's a cheat food or something
like that that you want to work in but
you have to know those calories too
because even on cheat days you have to
be
responsible for tracking those calories
because if you don't know then you can't
say what's going on right you just can't
say oh i've been in a deficit you don't
know because you can gain it all back
really quickly especially you know if
your body has a propensity to take that
food that you consume and put it
in uh stored body fat which is going to
be true
if you
uh or somebody who's
five three two forty five sorry sorry to
call you up but again this is anonymous
you know i'm not actually naming
anybody's name so i might be talking
about a totally made-up person
how can you fat shame
an anonymous hypothetical individual
let's see why don't we go onto some
because we were so serious just then
just as far as like can we do uh uh
yes here
there we go you knew oh there we go juji
mufu i mentioned him before what he's
doing here it's like just wake me up in
the morning let's do a little bit of
coffee put it in the mug i'm on the
treadmill let's throw it on my face
it must not be hot or maybe it is i
don't know maybe he's throwing hot
coffee on his face and i don't even
realize that he's burning his face off
and we haven't seen him post lately
because he had to have a facial
transplant surgery
after
his skin melted off due to having
mcdonald's level hot coffee poured on
his face
there we go try this killer leg workout
on leg day curls 4 by 8 to 12.
leave
that was great
because it also mocks that pattern it's
like try this killer workout it's like
yeah that's like the most basic [ __ ]
you know like try this kill your chest
workout bench press
pec deck
whoa killer workout
mm-hmm here we go you know it's never
going to get old to me guys puking when
they dead lift
just spraying it out and it's amazing to
me that it like
[Laughter]
this guy's going back and forth through
the
puke go back in the mouth and come right
back out
it's glorious but i do kind of enjoy
that because it just shows you it gives
you an appreciation
for the distance and the volume right
dude flexi she's sleeping with
other dudes
so am i
[Laughter]
joke's on you sweetie
i'm getting [ __ ] too
oh [ __ ] yeah and so this is a guy on a
treble right now pulling a 25 pound
weight
out of his pants and
and this is where i got inspiration to
start training for my haters because
i'll run up on you oh not with a gun
with weights
to beat the brakes off you dude
for real dawg
what do we got here okay we got this guy
doing rope hammer curls good one rep
look looking great man
oh he's he's he's licking it
like it's a penis and i just think this
is why we can't have nice gyms because
as i've mentioned before this kind of
debauchery and a sexual innuendo
doesn't have a place at the gym to me
i'm somebody who's a lifting purist i
think lifting and sexual intercourse
should be kept totally separate and i
don't even want implied sex acts i don't
want you rubbing up on somebody's butt
while they do a squat i don't want you
licking the tricep rope like you're
performing fellatio on your partner i
think that's disgusting i think it's
unwarranted i think that person
should have a lifetime ban from not just
that gym but any gym he ever tries to
enter into for the rest of his life okay
and i think if he tries to buy equipment
online
they should ban that too
he shouldn't be allowed to work out you
know
and here is the serious one okay the
trainer gets caught on camera being a
pervert and when i stand up for myself
he threatens to call the police and
revoke my membership
this is a super viral video going around
and disclaimer of course women get
harassed at the gym and everywhere but
this is one of those instances where
oh you made a mistake uploading this
because you don't realize that it makes
you look terrible as a woman a guy
across the gym turns around a trainer
there for about a half second like goes
like this and like
looks at her and you just don't know i
mean i turn over my shoulder and look at
my self in the mirror all the time so
you don't know and whenever people say
you know this person is looking at me
i'm like
yeah i look at people all the time
unthinkingly
i look at people i'm attracted to i look
at people i don't give a [ __ ] about just
because i'm taking in visual information
maybe you have a cool haircut or
something maybe i like your shoes
maybe your butt is eating your shorts i
think a lot of people look at me for
that exact same reason so
when i see this you can't attribute that
to somebody looking and again you're in
a public space you should assume that
people are going to look at you
especially
when you're you know in a skimpy outfit
uh i just it tells me that
you know you're entitled
you need attention
right you want to prove to yourself that
you know women always do this or some
women who
it's a category of women not all women
but they go like oh my god i can kind of
hitting me they're acting annoyed but
it's really about
telling other people that they were
getting attention from men maybe to
compete
with other women who get much more
attention they want to be part of the
conversation of like oh my god men are
so annoying like always hitting on me
it's such a problem for me
and then they do stuff like this and
humiliate themselves on a world scale
congratulations okay we got something
hella psychological here now
i'm gonna read it off my thing and this
is about somebody with bpd and i just
want to read that real quick because i
thought it was an interesting insight
again because amber heard has bbt you
know if you run into this in your real
life
i just think it's interesting to
understand
that person's perspective because i also
believe that we shouldn't stigmatize
although it's important to recognize
when you're dealing with somebody who
potentially has a form of mental illness
or
has a personality disorder it's
very important to recognize those traits
as they often correlate with other
things and you can you know predict the
problems that you might have with that
person or the things that will you know
that maybe seem like a one-time extreme
incident but then might actually long
term form a pattern that could
potentially harm you and just you know
be something that you could prevent by
avoiding that person or that situation
or dealing with it in a different way i
also think that you should
you know still have empathy for any
person
uh who's acting a certain way because
they don't want to act that way and they
don't want to feel those things and
borderline personality in particular
um
you know somebody like amber heard who
maybe has a touch more of the narcissism
or sociopathy or something where you're
willing to do
malicious things on a bigger scale that
i would say are very ill-advised and of
course she wants to
place that blame on like her lawyers
advising her whatever but she just seems
like long term she doesn't have a lot of
good reviews but even that being said
you know even if she is the worst of the
worst
and i do think she has borderline but
that shouldn't stigmatize other people
with it or prevent us from giving
sympathy to
a people because that experience in and
of itself
can be very tumultuous and painful and
that's the reason that we see these
people you know acting out in anger it's
not pleasant
to have certain conditions you know
where you're experiencing uh a lot of
negative emotions all the time this
person messaged me and said
uh or actually was a comment i had bpd
something snapped in my head when
someone used a therapeutic technique on
me a line of questioning to get to the
core of an immoral belief i had i had
the idea that if people could
conceptualize the pain i was in
things would change
i thought people only care or do things
when it gets to the point you get angry
or cause a scene
and that was just an accepted belief of
mine i'd also get angry at things very
quickly blowing up a situation like that
kind of worked but eventually people get
sick of it true
and sick of constantly having you fear
their motives or doubt their honesty
when they get numb to your pain and
breakdowns
which only makes it worse because you
can see it and feel the relationship
ending and not be able to do anything
about it right they fear abandonment
very much this is one of the big signs
of someone with borderline personality
but they also
you know uh
cause things that would make people want
to abandon them and sort of push people
to abandon them but then also fear that
you feel like nobody cares and that
you're the worst piece of ish ever but
what made me change was this technique
leading to a realization that i was
causing suffering to other people so
they'd conceptualize my pain
let me say that again
i was causing suffering to other people
so they'd conceptualize my pain and as
you said before that's an immoral sort
of approach to life right because people
can
conceptualize your pain without you
causing them the same pain
suffering begets suffering and wellness
begets wellness has never felt so real i
also had the realization that i was
seeking sympathy for my trauma
to validate my trauma to everyone who i
let close to me so they would know i had
pain in my life and it would justify my
flaws to that person but the fact was i
was making people suffer and then trying
to justify it with the fact i've
suffered
that is absolutely evil i thought and my
mind changed i also realized that
sympathy doesn't get you anywhere
i would agree and people often
with personality
disorders you know so surpassed
narcissists psychopaths uh you know
bpd's apparently
probably mocking villains too uh
they
they use they weaponize sympathy because
it allows you to get certain things and
people to not question you it opens
doors and but it is manipulative anyway
uh
i was on this line about sympathy
god damn it
i was making people suffer and then
trying to justify it with the fact i've
suffered that is absolutely evil
i thought and my mind changed i also
realized sympathy doesn't get you
anywhere people can know and
conceptualize your pain and things will
stay the same
you won't be justified and hurting
people and your life won't feel any
better either
this happened after my discovery of
jordan peterson
this has all been an advertisement for
jordan peterson
get uh you know 12 rules for life right
now it all happened in a flash of memory
images of my past it seemed so simple
but it brought my neuroticism down from
95 to 30 to 40. i had been suffering
with suicidal thoughts and eating
disorder self-harm extreme heated
frustration that i felt was too big for
my body to handle for 14 years i was in
such pain living with living was
exhausting i found out what happened to
me was memory reconsolidation i
unraveled programming in my mind that
elicited a fear response when whatever
arbitrary thing triggered me into this
downward spiral of emotional turmoil it
literally broke synapses in my brain and
i felt it i felt it felt like a snap and
then a burst like ten thousand pinballs
shooting all over a pinball machine
but they were tingly and cold and a
physical pressure felt lifted off of me
as soon as i was done i said i think you
fixed me and i have been right so far
going on four years since my self-hate
suicidal times that occurred daily
maybe that's boring i don't know it just
occurred to me that this is an insight a
really honest insight into somebody's
mind who dealt with suffering and a
personality disorder and sometimes
the act of self-reflection and doing
deliberate self-reflection triggered by
whatever
can cause realizations that something
you're doing is wrong because you know
people don't think of themselves as bad
or evil they justify the behaviors that
other people think
are evil bad immoral whatever
and they just don't self-reflect or
listen to criticism of that you know
that's why i'm always open to criticism
but be articulate don't just say like
mark is a narcissist and then list the
traits of narcissism
i know i'm a narcissist i'm just
challenging you all to prove it
um
but i thought that was an interesting
insight because
uh
it's easy to make people in other you
know and forget that even if that person
is causing harm or damage or whatever or
stigmatized in some way there's still a
person and they're probably acting out
because they're really unhappy and
that's why i have sympathy
and empathy for all you guys on the
subreddit
because obviously you're not happy
and happy people don't harass other
people online for sport
but happy people do talk [ __ ] sometimes
for support you know just for fun just
to be like oh what's up you know we
doing this we have a little roast battle
in the comments section that's cool
i'll do that
um
i'm gonna have two quick segments real
quick just in case you're hanging on to
go like when is this ending well it's
gonna end right now the hell chef harley
for this week we're gonna have a battle
between mcdonald's and erwin okay
the battle that everybody's been waiting
for because that's me every day around
one o'clock i'm like mcdonald's or
arowana yeah do i want to spend fifty
dollars or five dollars
see
and that's what i'm talking about
because in your mind or at least in my
mind i go i'm gonna spend like way more
at air one
and way less at mcdonald's but you see
casey the funny thing is the way i eat
oh yeah i get carried away i spend 20
bucks or more
at mcdonald's oh that's 100 at airwan
then right but here's the thing because
it's mostly like
you know
any fast food place you go to
it's not going to be
high quality protein you know except for
certain maybe chipotle or whatever like
you can kind of like increase the
protein a lot um
but the other day i got a big mac i got
a spicy chicken sandwich i'm just i'm
gonna admit what i got okay you can have
an insight in my mind as far as what i
do when i go to mcdonald's
had a big mac had a
spicy deluxe crispy chicken sandwich had
10 nuggets with the honey mustard and
then i believe on top of that i just had
the two guava and cream pies that may
sound disgusting but trust me it was
delicious now immediately after
finishing all the mcdonald's instant
bubble guts um
do i feel full kind of like not like you
feel more like bloated but you know like
something immediately feels off i think
we've all been there before it doesn't
feel great to eat a bunch of junk like
that but sometimes i just have in my
head and i do it and i try not to limit
that too much like like you can't ever
eat mcdonald's
i will but i just try not to make it a
habit now
the next day i go okay because before
that decision i was like i want to go to
everyone but i also want to go to
mcdonald's and i kind of wanted to be
back for work so i was like it's going
to be quicker to go here and here you
know
the next day i go to erwan
and get
uh the korean short ribs which are
delicious and then
two of these sides you know you can get
like uh
buffalo chicken or buffalo flavored
cauliflower they have these great
vegetable sides that you can get like
two sides and a protein so i got the
the korean bbq short ribs and a couple
vegetable sides
when you eat that i realized i was the
exact same amount of fullness and maybe
it was like 25 bucks right
if you just get that one thing i don't
get a drink because the drinks are like
ridiculously expensive and you don't get
anything on the side you can keep it to
like 25 bucks and i realized wait a
second
i'm actually full from this it satiates
me more and i don't have instant bubble
guts i guess erwin's the winner because
it was only five bucks more and i feel
like you know
yesterday i would have paid five bucks
to relieve myself of that bubble guts so
it kind of evens out
maybe even ten bucks i don't know
i've had hundred dollar bubble guts
before
true story
walking home you don't have a car and
you're like i need to knock on
somebody's door right now to ask them to
destroy their bathroom
let's just end on there you know because
again they're probably not going to top
that sentence of me telling a story when
i'm 13 years old walking back home from
the mall and getting mad at my friends
as they looked at me because i had to go
to the bathroom so bad i was ready to
poop on the sidewalk
you